I'm really proud of you guys you killed
it attaches here now get go home we
didn't result in them free and scattered
power outages in your head you're all
I've got left
brave it may be the flights not canceled
its careful
what are we gonna eat we only got
favored by a ball last night I was
hungry you know birds snow animals
it's up it's not like this is the first
time this happened I mean I mean it
could be worse right everyone sorry dad
no no okay okay nothing's wrong with
mark he's letting snow in more food
that's good in a cheeky embrace the cold
and break it you know it's definitely
hard we don't have to embrace the cold
no you can put on clothes
yeah break like a normal person right
Nick mark here is what you must to out
let it go up
I'm not wearing clothes
[Music]
Hey